all this action at the supreme court
comes as president biden attends the u.n
climate change conference in glasgow
scotland the president says the u.s is
ready to lead by example and he also
apologized for america's withdrawal from
the paris climate agreement under the
previous administration wishes is
traveling with the president and she's
in edinburgh of scotland uh wiisha good
morning to you
good morning tony and good morning to
everybody president biden is determined
to convince the world that the us is
back at the head of the table when it
comes to fighting climate change he
spoke about the overwhelming obligation
especially to help poorer countries
warning that the worst is yet to come
and the administration continues to call
out big polluters like china
climate change
is already ravaging the world
president biden agreed with world
leaders and climate activists who issued
one dire warning after another we are
digging our own graves over two million
of my fellow kenyans are facing climate
related starvation
delegations from almost 200 countries
are attending the cop 26 summit eager to
build on the 2015 paris climate accord
that set a goal of zeroing out global
carbon emissions by 2050. i do apologize
for the fact the united states
in the last administration pulled out of
the paris accords and put us sort of
behind
the eight ball other countries like
china and russia have rejected the
mid-century target even though they are
major contributors to pollution white
house national climate advisor gina
mccarthy who spoke with cbs news after a
climate town hall in glasgow
acknowledged that pushing beijing may
require tougher tools i have faith that
that china will come around but we know
that that their their goals right now
aren't sufficient to be able to address
their challenges is diplomacy enough no
probably not
so then what's the alternative it's
continuing to look for ways in which we
send economic signals about what me what
products we want to buy
and what we expect in those products
queen elizabeth who canceled her
attendance following medical advice
urged world leaders to rise above
politics we are doing this not for
ourselves
but for our children and our children's
children
and those who will follow in their
footsteps
despite all the promises that president
biden is making here in scotland now
that his own climate agenda back home is
in trouble once again as you guys were
talking about with major some experts
are skeptical that the u.s can even
honor its own commitments those are some
tough questions the president will
surely face during his press conference
tonight gail
all right everyone's looking to him for
the answers thank you weeja very much